you're familiar with glory all right you
know what glory already
yes so you know sometimes you know we
are sold a philosophy
by somebody who has had dramatic life
experiences that we haven't had right
but they impose their philosophies on to
you and you kind of sit there and say
i'm going to buy that but you shouldn't
buy that because it may not work for
your life it's extra but because the
other person's such a better salesperson
it's so much emotion into it you buy
into it right you got to be very careful
which philosophies of people you buy so
i remember when i interviewed her gloria
allred we're in our office i walk in
and you know she
she's a perfect like she's the for
people that know who glory already is
how do you define who she is michael
jordan of
sexual harassment lawsuits right can we
say that yeah an attractive older woman
accomplished by the way i had the most
incredible time sitting down with her
when the interview was done because
things got heated when the interview was
down i said can i hug you
she says you know what patrick all you
have to do is ask that's the key i'm
like okay so she gave me the biggest hug
we laughed it out but i pushed her she
pushed me i said look gloria you talk
about feminism and women's rights and
all this stuff how many people you got
working here a lot why is it that the
front desk clerk was a woman but all
your partners pictures on well they're
all men well
well are you how about you patrick are
you not a bigot it was like such an
interesting dynamic but then i said i
want to find out about this later lady
when i looked at her documentary looked
at study stuff on her when she was in
cancun do you know the story about what
happened to her in canada in mexico so
when she was younger in her early mid
20s very attractive girl
she goes to a doctor she meets a doctor
dr says let's go back to my practice i
want to show you my office in the office
she she he rapes her okay
and she keeps it to herself for a while
but she creates this
level of anger towards men right
so later on she gets married uh to this
man then they get a divorce i think
after she gets a divorce you know he
ends up committing suicide the guy kills
himself her first husband and the second
husband she gets married they get a
divorce she keeps the last name but
sue's the hell out of him and he saw
what happened to her daughter her
daughter is now kind of similar doing
what she's doing i don't know if you're
following the she's following her
footsteps similar personality strong
personality
and she's out there saying independent
women independent women independent
women independent women and women are
like she's right she's right she's right
and it may work for some but some
actually do want to have a family do
want to have you know do want to have a
husband do want to stay you know build
something together with them how do you
differentiate between
you know somebody who is selling a bag
of goods that maybe worked for her
because she had a painful experience how
do you process that how do you get
somebody who's listening to this saying
well she's right
versus saying i don't know if that
philosophy is going to work for me long
term it's it's very difficult to
make a rational argument with people who
are like seated and steeped in
emotionalism and anger is definitely an
emotion and resentment and and uh you
know
regret um revulsion there's all kinds of
different emotions that go along with
that so i can be the most rational guy
in the world and say here's the
statistics here's here's the dynamics
here's just the dots that i'm connecting
yeah i'm not going to change that
person's mind if we're if if she's
having an emotional
argument and i'm having a rational
argument because we're talking past each
other um my
most people when they have a a conflict
of interest or they have like oh you you
believe in a philosophy and i'm like no
i don't believe in a philosophy i
believe in empirical data here it is uh
the only way they can win that uh that
rational argument is by converting it
into an emotional argument and that's
you know in a nutshell kind of what
happens when you're trying to relate
um red pill awareness when you're trying
to relate the kind of material that i do
to people who are very
ego invested into like their
personalities are dependent on that
belief set so unless they get to a point
of crisis unless they get to a point of
of really kind of desperation or they
have you know through some miracle they
have some sort of insight about things
you're really probably not going to
change their minds about it
the best you can do is to present you
know pick your battles uh ask uh lead
the witness right ask uh pertinent
questions at the time when those when
those
topics arise
um but as far as like when we're talking
about like this
cultural narrative of the power in a
strong independent woman right now it's
practically a brand we've been talking
about the strong independent woman since
1970 since gloria steinem okay
and
why is that a broken philosophy well
it's a broken philosophy for a first
several years some people some people
swear by it independent of what what are
women independent of
men they're independent of men's
provisioning so when we go about
remember i told you how everything goes
back to the micro the micro level is
this for women women's mating strategy
is hypergamy okay and i mean that on two
fronts it's dual it's not just one like
a lot of people mistake hypergamy as oh
well women marry up it's not just about
that women also are looking for
short-term sexual genetic benefits they
want the hot guy in the foam cannon
party in cancun on spring break you know
they want the hot fireman that arouses
them and gets their blood boiling and
then they want the guy who's also like i
said attraction who is the guy who's a
good long-term security prospect so it's
cads versus dads that's the that's kind
of like the dynamic that women have to
choose they have to find the best fit
between those two things in today's
society really since 1970 we have
developed a a social order that has sold
women you don't need to worry about
long-term security we've got
we've got no fault divorce we've got
child support laws we've got the duluth
model of feminism we've got more women
in the workplace and just go on down the
line of all the benefits that have that
women have accrued since the time of the
sexual revolution all of those point to
one thing which is long-term security
for women so when we're talking about
like abortion on demand that's a
fail-safe for bad reproductive choices
that is the function of abortion is to
say you know what well i i he's not i
don't he's not a good prospect for the
future but this guy is and so therefore
we have that option just having that
option and that is exactly why women
will fight tooth and nail to keep
abortion legal that's number one you
think that's the reason absolutely
that's the function of it so women will
say well it's because of uh you know bad
to say what really what else is it i
mean is it is it a uh is it bad
philosophy is it bad religion is it bad
whatever so let's practice what is that
what is the purpose where's the label so
what you're saying is what you're saying
is if if a girl
hooks up with an nfl player she'll keep
the baby but if she hooks up with a
you know neighbor because one night she
was alone and he came he was a school
teacher a regular guy she may abort that
baby but keep the nfl that's what you're
saying and it's exactly why you have no
seat at the table when we start talking
about abortion laws you don't have a
uterus and therefore you don't get to
you don't have a say
you know what nfl trained on that by the
way just a side note nfl trained that
every time you have sex with a condom
flush the flesh account it was an mba
mba that yeah
i mean now it's everybody have you seen
what happened recently in the news and
then tabloids with drake yeah the hot
sauce and the condom situation you know
where he got that from was tom lycus
from back in the night
because i did i did a segment on that
and everyone's like tom like the time i
go there is that time
my question is like drake why are you
putting cholula sauce in a freaking
condom just flush it down the toilet i
don't know if it was an environment
i believe it was 2001 the nba released a
press release to all their players who
are on road trips because they had such
a high incidence of women that they were
sleeping with while they were on road
games
uh essentially they would use a condom
and the women would let's say inseminate
themselves with the leftovers in the
condom so that they could have a kid
with an nba player so that is a goal of
many of those it was so common that they
had to make a press release for that and
of course tom like is being the extreme
guy who has you know this is well you
should put tabasco sauce in there so
like when she does that but continue you
were saying continue you were you you
were going to a point there what
feminism and why it's not an official
strategy
and that's just one one factor that goes
along and so what we have done is we've
established a social order where men are
unnecessary and women today will say
this we don't need men i don't even know
man i don't need no man but i want a man
okay
what man do you want to get with what
man is that it's usually the guy who's
the quote-unquote stereotypical alpha
chad guy hot guy in the foam cannon
party she wants the alpha seed side of
hypergamy not the beta needs side
because at least there's this idea that
that side of security that side of her
mating strategy is going to be settled
and when they get to the point where
they're 33 34 35 years old and they're
asking me rolo where are all the good
guys how come i can't find a guy who is
you know makes more money than me or is
ready to go forward they're all so
irresponsible they're all threatened by
powerful strong powerful women and the
only answer i have for them is you have
created yourself into the man that you
wanted to marry
and so when when women hit me up and
they ask me about this and they say okay
well what can i do what can i do to be
uh to to find a long-term uh a long-term
guy and they're 34 35 years old and
these they get very very frustrated
they're like i'm i guess i'm going to
die alone you know i guess that they've
resigned themselves to to you know being
a spinster listener old spinster exactly
and so what i say is well you know what
are the men uh that you're looking for
what are they looking for in a woman
well they're looking for femininity
they're looking for a woman who's hot
they're looking for sexual availability
they're looking for a woman who can
nurture who might be a good mother in
the future i mean there's all of these
sort of conventional
feminine qualities that they don't
embody anymore and so when they say well
what do i got to do i got to play dumb i
got to play the ditzy blonde i've been
told my whole life
that i needed to be in charge and
powerful and everything else and as as
as patrick was saying just a minute ago
is women
want to be or they believe that they
need to be in those positions of power
because they can't depend on a man men
are irresponsible men are untrustworthy
men like gloria all read for example
i i don't need no man or they have a
very uh
misandrous uh attitude towards guys as a
result of life experience or whatever
but it doesn't even have to be something
as dramatic as that it can be simply
like watching disney pixar movies that
do nothing but say you can do anything
you can be an astronaut and have babies
at the same time and you can you know be
in the military and fight wars and you
can go and be a computer whatever it is
you know the sky's the limit girl and
you have you know three four generations
of women who are raised on that they
believe that they have to be the one who
provides that security for themselves so
as a result you have careerist women who
are getting more degrees than men we
constantly we point at men when we talk
about this but let's look at the stats
here there are more women who are
enrolled in college there are more women
in doctor programs there are more women
who get master's degrees um i mean just
educationally speaking we can we can you
know parse that out women are making
more money than than men are these days
are increasingly more anyways um and
then women spend more money that that is
part of the family unit right now with
ninety percent of of uh american homes
the woman is the one who makes all of
the big economic decisions for those
homes so it's not necessarily earning
capacity or this wage gap kind of thing
it's who is making the spending who's
doing the who's who holds the purse
strings and we can see that on the
family level and you can also see that
on the societal level as well so if you
go look at who's in charge of the imf
right now
who's in charge of the the fed who's in
charge of the with the emf right now
well yeah you look at i think it was on
zero hedge i had a really great story
about this is like the world's economies
are now controlled by women so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]